good morning Nick it's tuesday several
great books by people I know have
recently been adapted into movies or
will be soon and today I thought I would
talk about misconceptions around that
process but first some personal news I
have just read a screenplay adaptation
of my book Turtles all the way down
written by Elizabeth Berger and Isaac
apt acre who wrote love Simon and it's a
really beautiful script and I'm excited
now because I think it might actually
become a movie but I am also nervous
which I'll explain later but first
almost always book authors make exactly
one decision in the movie creation
process which is whether to sell the
rights to their book if you don't sell
the rights no one can make a movie if
you do sell the rights the people you
sell the rights to can usually make
whatever movie they want to like after I
sold the film rights for The Fault in
Our Stars to Fox 2000 they could have
set the movie on Mars only very
occasionally do authors get approval
over the casting or the script or the
director or anything now some authors
and I am lucky to be among them do get a
seat at the table when those big
decisions are being made but you get one
seat and it is a big table which by the
way is often good news because I think
usually casting directors are better at
casting movies than authors are like
when the casting for The Fault in Our
Stars was announced people were really
really mad that NAT Wolff was gonna play
Isaac because Isaac has blond hair in
the book and I was also concerned about
that but then in point of fact nat wolff
turned out to be the perfect Isaac and
also he is a national treasure and one
of my all-time favorite people now of
course sometimes bad decisions get made
but that's rarely the fault of one
person and authors often get criticism
for decisions they didn't make and
cannot control I don't just mean casting
but also when and where a movie is shot
which in the u.s. is determined mostly
by tax incentives or when and where a
movie is released which is determined by
marketing executives that most authors
never meet authors are however often
asked to communicate those decisions to
fans of the book which can be a
difficult thing to navigate and I have
messed it up a lot in the past hence
part of my affer mentioned nervousness
which brings me to a second
misconception that movie studios do not
care about fans of the book in my
experience anyway they care a lot about
fans of the book they just can't care
exclusively about them like my third
novel Paper Towns made the New York
Times bestseller list and sold much much
better than either of my previous books
Paper Towns sold about 50,000 copies in
its first year which was amazing but if
movie sells 50,000 tickets in its
opening weekend it is almost definitely
going to lose a lot of money in fact
even selling 500,000 tickets in an
opening weekend is usually considered a
failure
so studios have to balance the concerns
of fans with the need to reach a much
larger audience than most books reach
that's one of the reasons books can do
so many things that movies can't do I
mean even cheap movies usually cost like
plural millions of dollars to make
whereas books can be financially viable
on a much smaller scale and also the
cost of writing a car chase scene with
robots that are on fire is the same as
the cost of writing any other scene and
yet even though it's free I've still
never succeeded at writing a car chase
scene with burning robots I will someday
who are you kidding it's never gonna
happen you can't write plot welcome to
my book - people are talking in a room
sometimes they go outside
lastly I'm not sure it's fair to say
that the book is always better than the
movie the book is different from the
movie it has to be I don't really think
there's such a thing as a faithful
adaptation because you're turning
scratches on a page into visible humans
speaking audible words the life a
written story has in the mind of its
reader will always be intensely personal
in a way that movies can't be and movies
will always engage the senses of sight
and hearing in a way that books can't
movies are literally sensational and so
for me the question is not is the plot
the exact same or does the actor look
like the character I imagined because if
you go to a movie expecting to see a
book you're always gonna be at least a
little disappointed but a great movie
adaptation can explore the same
questions as a book and it can crack you
open in the same places and it can give
you that same self expanding experience
of empathy in the end a movie will never
succeed at being a great book but it can
be a great movie if you have questions
about the book - movie process please
leave them in comments I'll answer as
many as I can Hank I will see you on
Friday